in 2017 researchers tested 20
best-selling US sunscreens the good news
is that 19 of them met FDA standards the
bad news 9 of them didn't meet European
standards turns out different countries
have different rules for what makes a
safe sunscreen and US sunscreens may not
be protecting Americans as well as it
could when we lay in the Sun our skin
absorbs two types of UV light UVA and
UVB rays UVB light is higher energy and
can cause sun burns while UVA penetrates
deeper under the skin and can damage
skin cells along the bottom layer of
your epidermis
we know that UVB rays or the Rays that
cause some words but UVA rays are the
Rays that can actually cause skin cancer
so you actually want to cover the
spectrum on both of those I think a lot
of people get into a misconception that
I didn't get sunburn so I'm not at prone
to getting skin cancer which really
isn't true the big is concerned with the
u.s. sunscreen is how much protection
you're getting from cancer-causing UVA
rays for decades FDA regulations
required that sunscreens protect against
UVB but not necessarily against UVA
meanwhile rates for melanoma a dangerous
form of skin cancer kept climbing in the
US then in 2012 the FDA updated its
regulations on labeling and testing so
that manufacturers must now let
customers know if it's sunscreen
protects against both UVB and UVA that's
what the broad-spectrum label on your
sunscreen means for example and while
this is a good first step there's still
no regulation on how much protection
you're getting from UVA so there's no
way to tell we need to be cognizant of
the fact that when the sunscreen says
it's broad-spectrum UVA and UVB
protecting that does mean you're going
to get protection against those rays
however what it does not mean is that
it's going to block out all of the Rays
and that's where US sunscreens fall
short and I will say that I do think we
are behind
other countries globally particularly
some of our European counterparts in
getting new sunscreen ingredients
approved overall there has not been much
change in u.s. sunscreen composition and
what our sunscreens are made up of in
the past several years the FDA has
approved 16 active ingredients that
protect against UV radiation but only
some protect against both UVB and UVA
rays for comparison Europe requires that
all of its more than 20 active
ingredients protect against both other
organizations are really advocating with
the FDA that they need to really speed
up the approval process for new
sunscreen ingredients because it's what
these ingredients that we can probably
get even better coverage and better
protection and maybe even get something
that's easier to apply that's easier on
the skin that doesn't have any harmful
side effects for patients you can
purchase sunscreens from other countries
online but if you plan on sticking with
American sunscreens look for the broad
spectrum label and don't buy anything
below SPF 30 the higher the SPF
definitely the better but we definitely
don't want anyone going below a 30 and
think about if you're someone who has a
history of a melanoma you use an SPF 30
you're blocking out let's say 98% of the
harmful rays however what about the
remaining 2% that 2% may be something
that could be potential putting you at a
risk down the road